hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the Halloween
edition of five nights at Freddy's now
there is an experiment that I want to
run before I get into the rest of this
game I wanted to see what blind mode was
like but also I wanted to see how
fredbear moves because oh my god I'm
completely blind oh god I don't even
have my map I activated the map Oh God
crap oh god oh god I don't I don't know
what I'm doing oh wait where am i oh
come on what what happened oh god damn
it oh god damn it oh that sucked
I'm so lost and I know you guys were
lost too because you probably couldn't
you can skyed oh okay so I turned on my
mouse so that you can actually see where
I'm clicking and I think there's a
should there should be some sort of
click effect so that you know where I'm
clicking when it's happening and for
added bonus I'm gonna actually blindfold
myself but I don't have a blind just so
you know I ain't fibbin right no fibbin
fibber I ain't a flipping not oh god I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna know who what is
the point
I'm already blind why do I need to
blindfold myself oh no I'm an idiot hey
let me do the way I do and you can do am
I even pointed to the camera yeah that's
right what was I saying I'm blind I got
see where I'm going so I can actually
start this bull oh I won't know where
I'm clicking well this is stupid I won't
know what if I click the wrong place how
will I know well this I'm an idiot I
can't do this I have no idea what I'm
trying to do there that was stupid
that was a dumb idea why did why did I
even bother with it anyway now let's get
back to the actual game here well
alright so now you guys can see where
I'm clicking hopefully and that's good
enough good enough good enough okay so
I'm gonna do this blind okay I'm pretty
sure this is the only night that I would
be comfortable actually doing this blind
on so I gotta pay attention here we go
oh boy let's do this okay you can see my
mass now left side going back to the
right side on to the right side again
Oh change his mind nope
wait back on left I also learned that
you don't need to flick your flashlight
actually that's very bad if you do that
don't flick your flashlight just listen
you gotta listen okay left side now
is that door okay
hey what's he doing what's he doing okay
oh oh he likes that left side oh maybe
he doesn't oh okay
I think he picked oh god damn it son of
a [ __ ]
wait does that mean okay no no he's not
in the room he just stiff stepped okay
as nerve-racking as all hell
I can barely talk as I'm trying to
listen so go late I can barely talk okay
oh no come on oh no no no no no no no no
no no [ __ ] what happened where am I
god damn it well that say I made a 3
a.m. god damn this is hard this is fun
to watch nothing happening oh god it's
so hard blind mode is a [ __ ] well Marge
I think I just got to go in this total
silence I can't talk or else I'm gonna
everything's gonna go wrong
oh god oh god oh god what's going on
wait where am I oh hell oh god oh god oh
god oh god damn it I lost track of where
I was Oh Frick I knew he was like in the
closet or behind the bed I tried to go
there and then I couldn't do anything
man this stinks on ice oh that's not
good
that's not good oh god oh god oh no oh
no crap to the right
okay
that sounds yeah he's inside
Oh God Oh God oh he's not in Xion Xion
he's in he's in he's in Oh
Oh
my heart's pounding like out of my chest
I really don't know if this is actually
interesting for you guys to watch but
holy crap I can do it think he's still
in the hallway
because if you hear steps while he's
laughing he ain't inside no no no no no
no no if you hear steps while he's
laughing he's not supposed to be inside
that's like the rule
could you pick a side
oh come on this son of a [ __ ] would
just stop for one goddamn second I'd be
able to live my life to the maximum
happy happy
ah
oh oh oh no yeah yeah he said that was
inside my god I did it I'm so scared of
being lost
I'm so sad alone oh it's like isn't that
the rule if he steps and laughs it's
okay he stepped after the laughs which
means he's definitely still inside or
outside
Oh God wait okay that means he's inside
nope yep okay I think whoa I think I got
him wait what's that oh no no we can't
be it's so hard it's so hard
it's so hard how close as I wanted what
I did so good uh-oh I never know what
the lap I'm pretty sure that he was
still at the door and for some reason he
takes forever to go away from the door
know what but I I've probably if you
don't move he gets you anyway ah that's
so stupid I was just waiting I was
waiting
oh my god my brain is on fire and my
heart is aflame well there you go that's
blind mode welcomed this is the weirdest
let's play ever cuz you hardly saw a
thing now all that's left is six-night
and I know that the marionette comes
into play in that night so if there's
nothing else to do besides the other
challenge modes that might be the last
episode of the Halloween update but
until then I'm gonna go lay down take a
nap
I'm not okay I do kind of want to see
what yeah I've already already died to
him so oh there's mangle hi mangle
there's Fred bear hi Fred bear Oh God oh
hey well then aren't you just a delight
I can't wait to dance with you I'm not
gonna do it blind that's for damn sure
but okay
on my way then so thank you everybody so
much for watching there's more
challenges left but I don't know when
I'm gonna get to them so thanks again
and as always I will see